ces boules de couleurs on les verra plus
dans le village gai de montréal
c'est la fin d'une époque jamais jamais
j'aurais jamais imaginé que le public
dans le village devient des
représentatif de montréal c'est quand
même assez extraordinaire
leur créateur a décidé que le concept a
fait son temps on laisse la place aux
jeunes
moi je crois que les jeunes ont quelque
chose à dire qu'une différent de ce que
moi j'avais à dire c'est sûr que les
gens comme nous tous on avait il y avait
un sentiment de déception et de ce mât
de peine parce que s'est attaché
beaucoup à ce projet là les commerçants
du village ont lancé un appel à projet
international pour trouver un nouveau
concept le gagnant sera dévoilé à la fin
octobre
montreal ville inclusive c'est un peu
notre branding et de fer voyagiste
branding à l'international c'est
fondamental donc c'est important de dire
aux gens de travers le monde
montréal ckoi en quelques instants et
surtout en images donc les boulons qui
troublent usa
ce ne sera pas facile de trouver une
idée aussi simple et aussi forte
ce n'est pas tout trouvé un concept
encore faut-il que les gens se
l'approprient
effectivement il ya plus de quatre
passes assez instagram et certains
autres réseaux sociaux les guide
touristique papier demeure mais au
niveau de l'image effectivement c'est
les réseaux sociaux compris la place
mais difficile de prédire ce qui
suscitera l'adhésion du grand public
nos tour eiffel à nous la montreal
disons le c'est la biosphère c'est le
sait la sphère de géodésique de
buckminster fuller
mais en même temps quelqu'un qui
l'aurait plus loin des quelqu'un qui a
fait une autre boule orange c'est le en
jullet puis ça a connu plus de succès je
dirais peut-être pas critique mais
certainement auprès de l'imaginaire de
la population
malgré le retrait des boules montréal
continue de jouir de plusieurs lieux et
symboles emblématiques les lacroix et le
mont royal le stade olympique et le mort
il ya les escaliers y aller festival et
l'oratoire saint-joseph et la basilique
les experts s'entendent pour dire que
montréal gagne 1 mettre en valeur ses
symbole distinctif à encourager la
création de symbole fort pour éviter que
les comptes prend toute la place et
s'impose comme le véritable symbole de
la métropole il si nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal